[Music]
so the UK has officially left the
European Union and that means no more
rather than European politicians in
buildings like this one right well no
not quite
no cherry-picking at all no way this is
all about a giant puzzle and breakfast
has left behind plenty of holes that now
have to be filled in so we have to find
a new way of putting all these pieces
back together again hope you got the
message by now we've made a choice we
want a comprehensive free trade
agreement similar to Canada's let's
start with a really big one and that's
trade can Britain and Europe really come
up with a deal that would mean no
tariffs and no quotas and things being
sold between the two sides turrets are
taxes which mean imports but become
expensive in other words French cheese
and German cars would get pricier in
theory avoiding that sounds like a
no-brainer but there are lots and lots
of things that will have to be
negotiated will the new rules about
trade in Northern Ireland really work as
seamlessly as promised and talking of
tough problems who's going to be allowed
to fish in British waters from now on
everywhere you look there are problems
to be sorted will British banks and
financial Giants be allowed to sell
their services to European companies
what about cooperation on security and
policing and then there's our
information and data how's that going to
be shared and who's going to monitor it
and what about the status of Brits
living in Europe who don't know what
regulations they're going to face
then all those questions about travel
which queue will British people use at a
European Airport will mobile phones
become more expensive to use in Europe
will cats travel with easily as they do
now leading the talks for Europe the
chief brexit negotiator Michel Barnier
who reports to the President of the
European Commission Ursula from the lion
and behind them 27 European nations who
will all have different ideas about what
the deal should look like the UK has
voted out so much to decide and so
little time the EU has taken years to
negotiate trade deals but this time the
deadline is fast approaching the end of
2020 in theory it could be extended but
Boris Johnson is adamant he wants to
stick to the deadline and plenty of
European politicians have told me the
same that they're sick and tired of
talking about brexit they just want to
get it over and done so yes the UK has
left the European Union but the story of
brexit has still got a fair way to go
because when it comes to puzzles this
one may take a little while to solve
[Music]
you